two one
welcome to juicy in genomic track on day
two
of the apj genetic solution tour 2020
my name is janice core and i'm your
moderator for this session
this session will focus on
authenticating human cell line
and normalizations of microrna
expressions
first we will hear from dr steve jackson
who is a senior member of the r d team
at thermofishes scientific
he has over 10 years of experience in
genetic analysis technology
and helped develop solutions for the
research and healthcare
markets leveraging vary technologies
such as capillary electrophoresis
digital pcr next generation sequencing
and micro
array analysis at thermal fusion
scientific
today he will be talking to us about the
complete workflow for the cell line
authentications
car t and ipsc sample matching
true analysis of highly variable short
tendon repeat sdr
if there's any question arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following his presentation
please join me in welcoming steve
hello thank you for joining us uh my
name is steve jackson i work with the
content engine team at thermal fisher
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
today about
how you can use our reagents
specifically our cell line
authentication kits
to make sure that your human samples are
what you think they are
knowing what exactly is in your test
tube now this is a this is going to
cover the fact that a lot of human
research these days is making use of
cells
that are are human cells that are taken
from
individuals and and either passaged in
culture or um manipulated in culture
before putting back into the individual
for uh for
therapeutic research purposes and so a
big problem is is making sure that
those cells are what you think they are
because you don't want to be putting the
wrong cells back
or studying the wrong cells in your
research
so exovivo cells are defined as a
human cells that are taken out of a
tissue blood tissue any kind of other
kind of tissue
and grown in culture um grown outside of
the living organism ex vivo
and as i mentioned a lot of these xp
vocal obtained cells are being used for
a lot of very important research
and and um and health purposes
um and so why is it important to confirm
the identity of these ex people human
cells well
um it's important to confirm yet any of
these cells
um to yes that you know exactly what
you're dealing with
one of the ways that this is done is
that you can confirm the identity of
existing cell lines by comparing their
identity to what is known about them
in standardized databases like atcc or
the rican databases
for for existing cell lines they have a
database
of markers that allow you to double
check and make sure that your gila cells
are actually helo cells
another time this is important is when
you're establishing a new cell line in
vitro if you have a new tumor cell line
that you have taken out of a
individual and you're growing that in
culture and you want to to
you know kind of stamp it or you know uh
provide some kind of fingerprint
of that cell line so that when you're
when you're doing experiments later on
you go back and say aha this is still
the cell
characteristics that that that i had
started
with when i started these experiments
another uh
reason this is important is if you're
tracking um human xenografts in mouse
models
you've taken a cell you've put it into a
mouse you've grown a tumor and now you
want to see what percentage of that or
you know you want to verify that that
tumor is coming from a human cell
um the character the um the kids i'll
describe for you
can be used for those purposes as well
and then finally for induced pluripotent
stem cell research and for car t
research you're taking cells out of of
an individual
you manipulate them in vitro and then um
you want to
make sure that the you before you do
something with those cells to
to um to uh
to put back in that individual or to to
make sure that they're
there are matched um you'll want to make
sure that the fingerprints of those
cells are the same
as what you uh as what you started from
after you've
you've made them um stem cells you want
to make sure those stem cells that
you've derived
match the characteristics of the
individual that you've got them from in
the first place
so uh making these these these
fingerprints or these profiles are very
important
one big reason for doing this again
coming back to cell lines is that
there are a very large number of cell
lines that have been misidentified
there are over 500 human cell lines that
are just simply wrong
in fact there are over 700 publications
using the mda
mb 435 cell line which is originally
described as a breast cancer cell line
but looking at gene expression patterns
and other things
it was later determined to be a skin
melanoma and so
um over 700 publications of a cell line
that was thought to be a breast cancer
cell line
are actually based off of a melanoma
cell line so it's extremely important to
make sure that your
cell line is as accurate
it has become such a big deal that nih
and other granting agencies
are making it a requirement that you
have a plan for
authenticating your cell lines and
matching the identity of your human
samples over the course of your research
not only the nih but a growing list of
journals are requiring uh proof of
authentication before they will
even consider publishing their paper
this
slide is a few years old now and i'm
sure there are many more cell uh
publications now the demand that uh that
in your
materials and methods you have proof um
that you have that you show that your
cells
are are matched to what you think they
should be
and that you are actually looking at at
you know the cells that that
you started off with so for cell lines
and for some of these other exercise
therapies it's extremely important to to
be able to show that that they are
correct
so how do we do this uh the most easy
way to think about this is by making a
dna profile
you probably know about this uh from
from um
um
tv shows and and other things where uh
forensics where you're looking at uh
making a molecular fingerprint of an
individual here
the the molecular fingerprint is used to
uh to differentiate tumor individuals
based on their their pattern of alleles
they have at highly variant loci
so this is a cartoon of the of the human
genome with a number of different
chromosomes highlighted
and on these chromosomes there are these
str regions
short tandem repeat regions where
there's extreme variability in the
length of these str's
these are used to to then make a
a very distinctive fingerprint for
individuals which is a
very um very often unique to that
individual here
the way this is done is that these
repeats as i mentioned are short
sequences
um of you know between four and eight
nucleotides long
these can can um can um
can vary you know in their length the
number of repeats that are present so
for example
this individual here has one allele
where there are seven repeats
and another allele where there are eight
repeats you can design pcr primers then
that will flank this
str region and amplify them up to get a
fragment that is going to be
a specific size for seven repeats and a
slightly longer size for eight repeats
again these strs are highly polymorphic
in the human population
the allele length can be determined by
the number of repeated units like i just
mentioned here and multiplex pcr
is set up for for looking at a large
number of these different different
str's at a time
and the combination of these strs then
tell you the military fingerprint of
that individual
now in our cla identifier kits and on
our cla global filer kits we provide
an allelic ladder which is used to help
line up the these fragment lengths to uh
known alleles
what we have here is is the uh the
electropherogram
of four different channels of the
allelic ladder showing the different
peaks corresponding different sizes
of the possible alleles that are present
in the sample now the way that you do
the experiment is that you you take a
genomic dna preparation from
from the cell line or from the uh the
pluripotent stem cell or whatever
you're trying to analyze here you you
use the cla identifier or the cla global
filer kit to amplify up
and you run it on your on your ce
instrument and you compare the the
the pattern of peaks that you see in
your uh in your unknown
to the ladder in this case here this
m4a4 gfp it's a cell line that i have
been using
um for various purposes over the years
and you can see that that you know it
provides a distinct profile of um
of of peaks which is unique to that cell
line
now the the analysis of the peaks the
the the
matching of the peak length to the
allele length is done by the software uh
both gene mapper and our cloud-based
software will do this for you so it's
very easy then
to go from from a genomic dna prep to ce
to a unique molecular fingerprint to to
authenticate your cells
and then it's simply a matter of
matching up the cells to known
profiles for for known cells or matching
them to what you have in your database
whereas for a cell line
so um the the thermal fissure has a
couple of different
uh kits for doing this we have one
called the cle identifier kit
it makes use of five different dies the
four different colors and an
internal uh sizing standard these five
dies cover
16 different str loci as um as indicated
here
on on the on the table all of these uh
these
loci are are covered by the atcc
and so the atcc database allows you to
to match the allele pattern you get with
a
cell line to what they have in their
database and verify that
your gila cells or your your m4a4 gfp
cells or whatever
other human cells you're using are are
correct
and also the rican and dsmz in europe
databases also have
a similar uh service so uh from this
combination you have a probability of a
match that is about six point one eight
times ten to the minus nineteenth
uh chance of there being an exact match
between unrelated individuals or under
unlimited cells now the cla global filer
kit makes use of six different dies
instead of five it has one additional
die
channel and we have twenty four
different low sides of the 16 in the
global filer kit
now this provides extra levels of
discrimination
you can see that now the chance of
finding a match between unrelated
individuals or unrelated cell lines is
now
7 times 10 to the minus 28 so extremely
rare
extremely unlikely to have a match for
unrelated
cells and the global filer kit is
extremely useful if you really want to
establish your own database because you
have
all these other indicators that are not
covered by other other panels
and it gives you extra levels of
discrimination
so we recommend the global filer kit if
you're starting a new project where
you're cataloging cataloging a large
number of different samples
um in your own database
so um as far as the identifier the cle
identifier kit goes we have two
different
versions of this one of them requires
purified dna but the workflow is very
easy
you first start off by purifying genomic
dna you amplify it using the radius in
the kit
you analyze it by ce and then and then
you run it out on your on your
instrument to analyze
the gene mapper itself and we've done
some experiments and you can you can
download our application which goes into
more detail about
how we've characterized the sensitivity
of the uh the identifier
plus kit uh using both seek studio and
ce
and for that matter 3130 instruments so
we know that we can get down to about
0.3 nanograms of input dna and still get
a completely accurate profile
another option which i think is a little
bit more convenient is using identifier
direct kit the cle identifier direct kit
in this case what you do is you spot out
some of your uh your um
your cell line that's in pbs or sell a
growth solution or something like that
on these nucleic cards
nucleic cards are treated paper that
will lyse the cells and immobilize dna
and stabilize the dna on the card itself
this provides a ver a dried spot then
which is very convenient for going
through and
and and coming back to a sample without
having to use up your freezer space you
just go back to this dried up card
you take a little punch out of the
center of the card here you amplify it
using the cla identifier direct kit
uh electrophoresis uh on our instruments
and analyze using gene mapper
um here's an indicator of the amount of
the uh of the punch that you take out of
these cards here very small punch goes
right into a pcr well
and added to the the identifier direct
kit to to do the experiment
and again this is covered in our
application you can go back to the
application note and find out you know
what uh what concentration of cells we
recommend
how they compare among the different
instruments uh and how easy it is to use
on the bottom lines we recommend at
least five times ten to the fifth cells
per male as a suspension
you spot that on the copan card let it
dry and then that's
stable for at least a year at room
temperature so very convenient to use
one final thing is the global filer kit
i don't have an example
that shows the complete profile of
global father but it's not necessary
because here what we've done is we have
matched
um a buccal swab with a t
cells derived from that same individual
the the uh
the buccal suave is shown here i'm sorry
the the t
cells were in culture the profile of one
channel is shown on the top of this
figure
and the buccal swab is shown here in the
bottom and you can tell that the cla
global filer kit is able to completely
match up these alleles and and the
pattern matches
uh perfectly so you have good confidence
that the buccal swab and the t
cells derived in that culture are from
the same individual
so the extra evil manipulation of human
cells
it makes use of a lot of different um
different uh
techniques um it's not just growing cell
lines but
as we are are growing more into induced
pluripotent stem cells and chimeric t
cells there are a lot of interest in
making sure that
manipulated cells match up to the
original donors
um in these cases it's critical in in
these studies know that
where the cells started from and confirm
that the identity of these cells
are what you think is correct
furthermore it is also critical to
confirm that once manipulated once
you've you've made
these uh these candidate cells into
pluripotent cells or car t
cells that these cells have the desired
characteristics
of of of either induced pluripotency
or uh they maintain the t cell
characteristics and they have maintained
genomic integrity in other words you
haven't introduced new mutations new
chromosomal
rearrangements by taking the cells out
and growing them in culture for a couple
of passages
and so thermo fisher scientific has a
complete portfolio of things that will
allow you to correctly quality control
any cells that you have taken out of
human beings and
manipulated in vitro we've got we've
gone over the str kits and
this is an example of showing how you
can use the the the
cla identifier and global fighter it's
to match up the profiles
of uh t cells and car t cells um
uh i'm sorry greater cartes regular t
cells and car t
manipulated cells from the same
individuals
we also have something called the
carrier scan microarray which allows you
to look at the entire
karyotype by molecular mechanisms it's a
very convenient way to look at uh
whether or not you have chromosome
deletions or smaller deletions
introduced
within the the chromosome
we have the oncoming assay that allows
you to see whether or not you have
introduced new mutations into oncogenic
genes of course you don't want to
introduce a ras mutation in
in your cells if you uh you've grown
them for a while before you put them
back into the individual
um you don't want to make sure that you
have not introduced a
novel um mutation in the manipulations
and find if you're doing induced potent
stem cell work you might want to
make use of the prime view microarrays
or tacman panels
to look at the the pluripotency
gene expression patterns in these
induced cells
these these are handy ways to to make
sure that you actually have
uh first of all taking the cells you've
made them pluripotent
and then after you then make the
pluripotent cells down into
a different differentiation pathway
these uh these kits will allow you to
make sure that you have you've made a
mesodermic derived cell
or an endodermic derived cell or or
something along those lines
so for those that are that are doing
ipsc research
on these pure potency determination
panels are very useful for for
quality quality control of cells and
making sure they are
doing what you want them to
so an example of how the induced for
potent stem cells can be used to match
with donors
i did an experiment with an individual
at the stanford
university stem cell core center he
provided me with a bunch of samples that
were blinded
and these were either donor samples
genomic dna from from donors
or from induced pluripotent stem cells
he made from these same donors
and he completely mixed them up and
blinded me to them because he wanted to
see how well the
str kids are able to match up and uh
and and and identify um
pairs of donor and and manipulated cells
um i used the the cld identifier kit to
do the experiment i
generated the profiles was able to match
up 100 accurately from 24 different
donors
um the the blinded donor
and and ipsc pairs and he was very
impressed by that
we wound up writing up an application
note um you can see uh dr wang here
um and and um you can you can see a
little bit more about the study in that
application note
in addition um the um in addition
in conjunction with the um the um
a group in carlsbad the the stem cell
research group in carlsbad we generated
a
paper that was published regenerative
medicine describes how you can use
the pluripotency panel and the str kits
for doing the quality control of ipscs
and
pluripotent stem cell research
just a couple more things the ideal time
to authenticate is once you're you have
taken a cell out of an individual
and before you do very much with it you
want to establish that fingerprint as
soon as you possibly can so that you you
have
a a known uh identity you can go back to
and you know after you have grown these
things in culture for a while or after
you've stored them at minus 80 for years
or something like that so
it's best to confirm the provenance or
the the the
establishment of cell lines when you
start to make them
um they're also good you should
authenticate when you're confirming an
existing uh confirming identity an
existing cell line
for example you receive a a a group of
hela cells or an alcohol hela cells
from uh from your your colleague down
the hall you want to make sure that they
are hela cells and so
you can you know use the str kits to
verify they are
hela cells and you establish them with
that str panel
what that str genotype is before you
embark on your experimental
paradigm it's a good idea to make sure
after each passage that you haven't
contaminated yourselves with different
cells and cells are are still what you
think they should be so
it's a good idea to run an aliquot after
each passage or each couple of passages
again just to make sure that the cells
are
maintaining the identity that you want
them to and again when you receive a
cell line from
from either an individual or from a
public database um it's a good idea to
just run a check and make sure
that the molecular profile is correct
and there are guidelines for for how
good a match is a match um
basically uh there are a couple papers
that have shown that that if the uh
if the um look if you if you categorize
the the alleles you match them up to
known samples and
you use this formula here to
determine the percent that are matching
the uh
the reference and the these papers
recommend that if at least 80 percent of
the of the alleles match the reference
then the cells are related to each other
so that's a very good guideline that we
recommend following for
for knowing how good a match is a match
recognizing that over time some of the
cells may drift genetically a little bit
so just in conclusions i i just want to
say that
these str sequences are very useful for
authenticating human cell lines
um these are our cell lines that have
either been well established
or that are being used for uh for
ex-fivo cell therapies
or for even vaccine developments to make
sure that the cells that you're using in
your vaccine development
are the correct ones and you're using
what what you think you
should be using the identifier plus
and the and the uh the cla global filer
kits can be used with as little as
0.3 nanograms of genomic dna to
authenticate cell lines
um we recommend one nanogram but it can
go lower if the need
is there and as little as five times ten
to the fifth cells per ml can be used to
authenticate
cell lines using the copa nucleic cards
and the identifier direct kits
um i in data that i don't show here but
during the application note uh we can
see at least uh
if if contaminating cells are are part
of your population
and they make up at least 20 percent of
the population you can detect the
differences by using the event
the uh identifier and global filer kits
and finally thermo fisher scientific
provides tools and applications
that allow you to qc your cells that are
that are analyzing
vivo and these include not only
molecular fingerprinting but karyotype
analysis
oncogenic analysis and and pluripotency
analysis
so finally i thank you very much for
your time i'd also like to thank david
yoder phd
for uh doing a lot of the work behind
the the
characterization of the cla uh i
identify their panels
uh um lakshmipathy and her team
um in carlsbad for doing the uh um
car tea studies and the ipsc studies
i've talked about
and comedy varmint and her team for
support at thermal pressure scientific
and i thank you again for your time and
a good day
thank you steve for the excellent talk
we will now move into the
live q and a portions of the
presentations
as a reminder please submit your
question via the q and a
box there are several questions coming
through
the first questions when we pass a cell
line many times over the years
don't we expect to have changes in the
cell line
and what do you suggest to avoid major
changes to our stop of cell line
yes i would expect that over time that
there will be genetic drift
that you will you'll find that there are
rearrangements and chromosomes uh
and and um changes in the lengths and
the number of copies
of the str loci so yes over time growing
cells and culture will uh
you know will eventually acquire new
mutations and new characteristics
the way to overcome that is that once
you've established a cell line or in
your laboratory once you
obtain cells in your laboratory it's
good to freeze them away and use those
as a stock that you go back to as your
as your starting stock
and and continually uh freeze away cell
lines from sub passages of those
you go back to your that that initial
passage every like depending on how
quickly your cells find
you find your cells are changing go back
to that that initial passage this early
passage of cells
and pull them out when you see that the
change is too much
using str kits will allow you to sort of
uh see the drift a little bit because
um the the str's might change in their
um
number of alleles and the lengths of the
alleles
thank you steve our second question is
um
what you are presenting here are about
human cell lines does it true
apply for other animals species cell
line as well
absolutely um that you know any any cell
line you take out of an animal grow in
culture
will be subject to the same sorts of
genetic drifts and and and
possible contaminations um that human
cells do and and there are strs for the
various different organisms that can be
used in a similar way
unfortunately thermo fisher at this time
doesn't have kits available for
for doing strs on say mouse or rat or
or or kangaroo cell lines
but you might be able to find uh um in
the literature
some of the str loci that have been
defined for them and design primers and
analyze them in a similar manner
okay our third questions what are the
instruments used in the dilutions
experiment
um i did all the characterizations on
3130s
3500 and seek studio instruments
i used a variety of different polymer
lengths and
and uh polymers i'm sorry capillary
lengths and polymers
um and found that that gene mapper can
pretty much handle
you know um the the analysis um
pretty much equivalently on them it
would be important then to match up the
capillary length um with the with the
bins
um defined by by the the cla identifier
kits
um and the and the uh human forensics uh
um
um bins and panels that are that those
are based off of
okay thank you steve um so i think we'll
have the last two questions
uh in your opinion can a major brief
change
the behavior of the cell line towards
viruses for example
i'm sorry i didn't understand i could
repeat that
in your opinion can a major drift change
the behavior of the cell line towards
viruses for example
okay so if i understand the question can
can major drifting genetic drifting
change the behavior of a cell line
um in in response to viruses or
antivirals
um you know etc um the answer is is
eventually yes um it really kind of
depends on the virus
and the cell line on how quickly some of
those changes might happen
remember most of the time these things
happen semi randomly and so
um it's basically just a matter of time
before you start to see things that
affect the biology that you're studying
so the answer is yes but i can't give
you any kind of guideline as to how long
it would take before you would see
changes either in the drift or in the
biological responses you're measuring
thanks our last question would be where
could i download the dilution
experiment conducted on this device or
kit
the the experimental details are in the
application notes available on our web
page
i don't have the url in front of me but
you can contact your local
representative
to to find out what the exact um
url for the website would be
thank you steve again uh for the
excellence of
qns sessions our next speaker is dr
emily
behringer and dr haritari
lingam emily is the rnd scientist
for sample preparation bioscience at
thermal facial scientific
she has worked as a part of rnd for over
15 years
and has contributed to multiple projects
for a wide range of
sample types library preparation for
sequencing and purification and analysis
of exosome
harita is the senior product application
scientist
for the genetic science divisions of
thermo future scientific
she has over 10 years of experience in
product development on real-time pcr
essay
for gene expressions and microrna
analysis
today they will be talking to us about
how to identify stable express microrna
and the workflow to identify normalizer
in serum and plasma using tatman array
cards
plates and open array if there's any
questions arrived during the
presentations
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions in the following q and a
sessions
i would like to invite emily and harita
for the presentations
over to you emily and harita
hello thank you so much for having us um
today what we'll be presenting is
strategies to normalize
micro rna expression in serum and plasma
and so
very quickly the agenda we have on top
for today
first is very briefly to discuss why
we talk about microrna and kind of why
we'd like to use it
in different downstream applications
second
challenges to being able to normalize
microrna
to be able to get the most out of the
data and then
solutions and strategies to handle each
of these challenges and then a very
brief
q a session at the end
so first why the interest in microrna
there's actually several reasons that
make it a good analyte target
for further research and study
the first is it's a very well understood
regulation pathway
unique and ubiquitous to transcriptional
regulators which are well conserved
really another key feature is that
microrna they regulate multiple
messenger rnas and then you have a
messenger rna can be regulated by
several micrornas so
provide you with many targets of study
they also have roles in many human
diseases and so it makes them a very
good candidate
for biomarkers and potentially methods
of treatment
it's a very interesting analyte but not
without its challenges
and you can see here we've listed six
challenges from sample all the way to
analysis that we've run across
and also run across various papers when
working with
micro rna and so here you can see sample
type
is one of them micro rna is mostly of
interest in
biofluids and which present their own
challenges then of course you have a
donor to donor variation
um um when looking at the micro rna
they're
very differentially expressed from donor
to donor just normally
then of course sample collection
handling rna purification extraction
and storage and then of course quantity
and quality
all of these have the potential to
introduce variation
into your workflow which can make it
difficult
to discern if any changes you see in
expression pattern
are really due to a specific variable or
just inherent
to um the workflow you're using
and unfortunately for microrna it's
difficult to rely on standard methods
like endogenous controls
and so in our talk today we'll actually
um i didn't
identify not identify but um
kind of describe ways to handle four of
the
six um challenging um parts
to normalization collection handling
storage purification extraction
and then rna microrna quantity and
quality
so the first thing sample handling and
when you talk about sample handling
we talk about this is kind of collection
of the original sample any
pre-processing steps required and then
of course storage
prior to any use in a analysis workflow
and so sample handling again here you
can see that kind of defined the three
different
areas so a lot of variation in micro
iron expression
can be due to you know collection
pre-processing storage
you know affecting recovery affecting
you know for example if
when you collect a sample um you know if
you don't store it properly the
expression pattern changes from start to
finish and you're not able to get a real
idea
um of what is the true expression
pattern and what is just
a result of your process and so
um the easiest way to
for sample pre-processing is to kind of
standardize
you know and when i say pre-processing
for example this can include phase
separation mixing steps
um you know incubation is required for
example if you need plasma
from a blood tube you have to do the
phase separation to separate it from the
white and red blood cells um and so by
standardizing these different steps you
provide consistency
especially if you're receiving samples
from multiple different labs
or you know you have multiple
different collection events having a
standardized process
reduces variation and so you're able to
have more confidence in your results
um an example of this kind of
standardization
is an sop you know one was developed by
the early detection research network for
working with plasma and serum
and so it's made it much easier to
compare different data sets
and then to compare different samples
and donors
in addition to sample pre-processing
once that's complete and then you know
if you can't work with your sample right
away
um you know you do need to storage and
storage can be very important
um as we know micro rna even micro
re and generally micro microrna which is
often protected by exosomes or
protein complexes you know is very prone
to degradation and of course degradation
will harm or you know interfere with the
true expression pattern
and interfere with your downstream
analysis and so storage is important
generally unless you're using some type
of stabilization reagents such as rna
later
which gives you a little bit more
flexibility and temperature
the colder the better especially for
longer term storage
so um you know we like to store um
for example serum plasma at minus 80 or
colder if you're going to it's going to
be one week
more than one week between collection
and process you know however
um for you know if you're going to
collect your sample and process that
same day
then of course four degrees is fine for
those eight hours
so once you have your sample you've
stored it in properly
um another potential source of variation
is your rna purification
um you know and if you you
your rna purification method is subpar
then of course that'll affect your
recovery
and you know you may not be able to
detect
kind of lower occurring micrornas
and thus that will you know cause
variation or problems
detecting true expression pattern and so
when it comes to micrornas several
challenges to consider you do need a
strong lysis step as i mentioned a lot
of micrornas are stored in exosomes or
protein complexes and so you need a
strong lysis in order to
release the micrornas from that and so
the way to do that is through
organic solvents for example trisol or a
mechanical or enzymatic lysis
such as with proteinase k you also want
to try to remove
as much as dna as possible to enrich the
concentration of your micro rna as much
as possible to be able to
detect you know very low occurring
as well as the higher occurring targets
and so there's several methods that will
provide the strong license step
as well as dna removal the first is your
organic base this
is going to be your trisol combined with
an ethanol
cleanup or a column cleanup at the end
there's your column-based systems for
example um like the mirvanna paris
these are more um but again these do
still require kind of more organic up
front
then finally you have your high
throughput high throughput solutions
your magnetic bead based
this is generally going to use your
enzymatic treatments
in order to laser sample so you are able
to easily
you know process a high throughput or a
large number of samples at one time
um you know however as
rna purification even if you have a good
method there is still some donor to
donor variation to consider which can
affect your ability to recover
um you know as much rna as possible from
your sample
and so you want to make sure that your
purification method or extraction method
is performing optimally for all your
samples and a good way to do this is by
using an extraction control to monitor
recovery um you know it's it's
it's kind of a good um check or a good
addition um to use with your
normalization
method to really give you confidence
that the expression pattern differences
you see
are true and real
and so unfortunately for micro rna for
message rna you can use a lot of times
endogenous
messenger rna um it's pretty stable
between donors azure control but for
micro rna this isn't
as useful or as consistent
and so for microrna we
try to use with more synthetic type of
samples and these include kind of
what i've been using is our nirvana
microrna mimics they're modified in
order to protect the rna
from anything in the sample that could
degrade it
and so it makes it ideal for use of
serum plasma so you can spike it into
your sample
and then monitor it all the way through
to the pcr detection
and so here's just an example of a
workflow
you can see i've used two c elegans
micro rna and spiked them into
human serum and plasma and then
extracted them with our magmax mirvana
kit
along with any microrna in the sample
and then performed pcr using our
attackman advanced microrna
workflow and so what you can see here
is looking at five different donors for
both serum plasma
if you look at the specific synthetic
microrna targets
the detection pattern is very consistent
from donor to donor so you're not seeing
a lot of effect from the donor
especially for the
um the lin 45p
the other nice thing is if you actually
um
you know here are two samples with the
spike in and then a sample with no spike
in and you can see
here we're looking at mir-16 targets
there is no effect on the expression
pattern of mere 16
um in the serum plasma by using the
spike in um
and so you're able to see good
extraction and detection
um all the way around so extraction
control is a good addition
to make sure your rna purification is
working
and then to make sure that any
normalization
also will work as well so at this point
i'm actually going to hand it off to my
colleague karita
to talk about the last two topics
all right emily thank you so much for
that nice overview
of sample handling purification
and now we will uh move on to our next
topic which is
how what are the solutions available to
um
quantify uh rna as well as uh
normalization techniques
so uh with respect to um the tools that
are available for quantification
we have two unique chemistries that are
offered
um by the taqman chemistry um the first
is the taqman microarray assays
these are assays which are designed
to specifically detect micrornas from
samples
and they come with a micrornas specific
reverse
transcription step followed by micrornas
specific
real-time detection of the target of
interest
the other chemistry that is uh offered
is also trackman based however this is
based on universal reverse transcription
wherein all uh micrornas that are
present in a sample
are reverse transcribed at the same time
for this technology we have poly
adenylation happening at the three prime
end and
adapter ligation at the five prime end
uh following cdna synthesis uh micrornas
of interest can be detected using
pacman advanced microrna assays so you
can see that
the two uh chemistries complement each
other very well
and can be used for specific
applications
to to get a broader coverage
both these chemistries are available in
four different formats
again to facilitate wide array of
research
um single tube assays as you can see
provide the maximum flexibility
um although these are more suitable for
load throughput
analysis and applications such as
verification
tachman array plates are
come with pre-spotted assays both
legacy and advanced assays more suitable
for
small to medium throughput analysis and
you can investigate anywhere from 96 to
384
samples ideal for verification and
discovery
contact array cards are also pre-spotted
um however these are probably more
suitable for discovery and
profiling studies and enable the
customer to
investigate up to eight different
samples at the same time our highest
throughput uh
platform is the open array arrays
place where um both chemistries
could be pre-spotted and they allow you
to
investigate up to 48 different samples
so those are the different uh
chemistries and
formats that are available for
quantification
with that i'm going to move on to
normalizing
rna qpcr data
and like most other micro
rna expression analysis micro rna
analysis is also
very critical and the reason behind that
is because
any variability that you observe in your
samples
should be a reflection of the biology
behind it
and hence normalization is important to
remove
um the differences that come in because
of
um you know samples uh
because of technical variability and
things like that
and so normalization is extremely
critical
micro rna qpcr
data is typically normalized um in three
different ways
and uh to make these different
strategies
more understandable i will go through
some of the case studies
um and we'll go delve a little deeper
into what each of these
strategies brings in so first
looking at global mean normalization um
to demonstrate global
global mean normalization which is often
used
to normalize large sets of data
in which several hundred or several
thousand targets
are investigated and how does this work
well in global mean normalization we
look
at targets that are common to all
samples in a study
identify the cq mean of all of these
targets
and then use the cq for cq median
and use the cq median as a normalization
factor
for all targets in the sample study
so that's the um the the basis of
global mean normalization and uh
for uh demonstrating that what we did
was we used
a small sample set of uh matched normal
and diseased
plasma from donors who were previously
identified
with chronic lymphocytic leukemia
samples were extracted stored
sorry stored and extracted as described
by emily in the few
earlier slides they were reversed
transcribed with the attackman advanced
micro rna serina synthesis kit and then
processed
on the taqman open array human advanced
microrna panel
these arrays were run on the quant
studio 12k
flex system and data from these was
analyzed
on the thermofisher connect using
our queue app and to demonstrate global
normalization
we used global normalization as
the option for data analysis what did we
find
uh we found that when data was analyzed
and we
looked at clustering of
differential gene expression between the
four samples that we looked at
um the data clustered by
the phenotype of the sample so the
disease samples were clustered together
while the normal samples were clustered
together which was what was expected
for the set of samples
all right so that's one way of
normalizing data
the other a very uh widely used
um strategy to normalize uh
gene expression data is the use of
endogenous or reference streams
now the challenge with um finding
reference genes for microscopy
is that most micrornas are
known to be variably expressed in in
tissues and biofluids and hence it's
very difficult to find
micrornas that are uniformly expressed
in any tissue
and especially in serum and plasma
historically
snow rnas and u6 rnas were used
as reference genes however because
the biogenesis of snow rnase um or u670
is
so different from that of micrornas
based on myki guidelines we are moving
away from that recommendation
um also my key guidelines suggest that
while normalizing
expression data using endogenous control
you should at least have
two or three different reference genes
which are stably expressed in a set of
samples
so because of these challenges one of
the first things
we recommend customers to do is to
identify
those reference genes or normalization
genes in their set of samples
and for that we have a very uh nicely
defined workflow which is a systematic
way of identifying these genes
um and we recommend using a spike in
control like the one that emily
mentioned earlier in the slides
in this case study we use the c elegans
mir 39 3p
as a spike in control into plasma
samples
and um rna was extracted uh using the
magmax marijuana kit followed by
cdna synthesis and qpcr this time
on the human endogenous control cards
the control cards consist of 30 unique
micrornas that are known to be
stably expressed in various samples
including serum and plasma
and this information is based on
literature so
we ran these cards on the
quantstudio ps7 system and analyze the
data on thermo fischer connect like
previously
this case study resulted in
identification of three micrornas in our
samples which were found to be
uniquely stable so these were
um hsa mirror 1983p hsa mirror 451a
and hsa merc 939 5b
once we had identified these
three genes as stably expressed in our
samples we use them as our reference
streams
in the sample set that was earlier run
through
the open array platform and this time
instead of choosing
global mean normalization for data
analysis
we chose endogenous controls and picked
the three genes
which were earlier identified as our
normalizing
um genes and what did we find
well we found that the uh differential
expression
um that we obtained from um
using global mean normalization and that
obtained using reference genes were was
remarkably concordant so very similar
kind of data you observe although keep
in mind that it is important that both
these strategies for normalization have
a place in its own
so global mean normalization is
typically recommended for
large high throughput studies and
reference genes could be used
both for high throughput studies and for
smaller sets of studies
but it's critical to identify the right
reference genes in
your set of samples
although i used open array to
demonstrate
the these different strategies i just
want to point out
that all of the panels that are
available in the open
array format are also available in the
taskman array
card format and here is a data set which
shows that the differential gene
expression data
you get from one format versus the other
in this case stack memory cards versus
open array
is very similar and they could be used
based on
particular application
with that a quick review of what we
learned today
we learned that it was important to
collect samples and store them
you know as recommended as emily went
through
the recommendation we also learned that
there's
many different um two different
chemistries that are available in
in many different formats which could be
custom used for different applications
and that data normalization of micro rna
qpcr data is
extremely critical and it's important to
choose the right strategy with that
we will now take some questions
thank you emily sarita for the excellent
talk
we will now move into the q live q and a
portions of the presentations
so we have several questions coming in
uh the first questions would be to emily
the extraction control can help to a
certain
extent but control rna is different from
the sample
including their micro environment
besides the extraction control are there
other ways of controlling the quality of
extractions
um so yeah to use that question um
there are other ways um generally this
will be
i'm assuming the question means a
testing for um
optimal lysis of the cells um
in the sample in order to get to the
nucleic acid um the easiest way are to
do actual intact cell
um you know to measure the ability to
recover
rna and to lyse
the spiking controls we discuss here are
more meant for normalization
[Music]
and to look specifically just at the rna
recovery
um not necessarily at the lysis
efficiency
thank you emily the second question for
you would be which method is the best
for rna extraction
for high purity yield
um so really that's going to depend on
kind of what throughput you need and the
sample type you're working with
you know our extraction methods both are
our high-throughput bead-based method
the magmax systems as well as our column
purcation like the purelink or the
standard nirvana both generate
a very high pure rna and high yield of
samples
so really both will work it just depends
on
you know which better fit your
throughput needs
thank you emily um so the next question
i would like to direct you harita
your question would be besides tag men
are they other chemistry for microrna
analysis by real-time qpcr
like any other platform for real-time
rt pcr that does not use pro
um so the two chemistries that we offer
for
both for rtq pcr are
based on the tax and probes
we do have other solutions which are
not rtqpcr based such as the microarray
assays the detection of microrna
but for rtq pcr we only have
tachman based assays
the second question for harita is can
the normalization be itself
the source of error in some cases
and how do you decide what kind of
normalization to use
yes normalization is actually a very key
component of
how the rtq pcr experiments
um you know can be analyzed and
the choice of normalization can skew the
data
any which way so it is very very
important to choose the right
methods for normalization and
i think we went through a couple of
different
ways it really depends upon your sample
and you know the kind of uh targets that
are uh stably expressed so if there is a
target that is stably expressed then
um they can be used as a normalizing
agent
otherwise um as we went through in the
presentation
spiking controls are a good choice um
or uh using global normalization so the
three options available and
um the kind of samples and the
availability of different
the presence of different uh target
targets which are normally expressed in
the samples will
decide which which methodology to choose
okay the last question we have can you
use more than one kind of normalization
or combined with certain essay
so uh you could
probably normalize your data two
different ways and
and make sure that you know the results
are
similar um they should if if the
technique is correct then
as i had shown in in my slides uh
no matter which way you normalize you
should still get a
very similar result the the
expression pattern should be similar
you could but i don't think there is a
way to really use
uh two different ways in a same
set of experiments like together it
might be difficult to do
i i'm not aware of any uh analysis
software which will
help you do that but you can definitely
do it two ways
thank you harita so with this
i would like to thank you for all the
questions and the speaker for your time
to be here today
as a final reminder any questions that
were submitted and were not answered
today by our speaker will be addressed
by via email this ends the qc in
genomics sessions
we will now take a 15-minute break
before we start the next session
in other tracks so you can have a coffee
and visit our booth
learn about some very exciting
promotions that is made available to you
where you can ask questions to our
thermal fusion representative
please also participate the scavenger
hunting games
look for our icons in the environment to
win prizes
there will be a pop-up survey appearing
in a minute
please help us to complete the survey
and thank you
and speak to you again in 15 minutes